- Batteries may be small,
but for the United Auto Workers
Union, they're a big deal.
- It's gonna change
the future of our union
and the future of our industry.
- At least 25,000 members of the UAW
have been striking simultaneously
at plants owned by GM,
Ford, and Stellantis,
as they demand increased
pay and better job security.
(strikers chanting)
And at the heart of their negotiations
lies a question around how the UAW
will fit into automakers plans
to build more and more EVs.
And whether the workers who make these
will become unionized.
- This union is really
fighting over positions
that aren't made yet.
- So what do America's
EV and battery ambitions
mean for the future of the UAW?
Let's find out.
(upbeat music)
(Strikers chanting Auto Workers Union)
So this is the first time
in the UAW's almost 90 year history
that the group has gone on strike
at all three automakers at the same time.
Part of the UAW's demands have been
for cost of living adjustments,
the right to strike over plant closures,
and a 40% pay rise over
the next four years.
And negotiations have been tricky.
- So I'll tell you what I'm
gonna do with their proposal.
I'm gonna file it in its proper place,
'cause that's where it belongs, the trash.
- A lot of the tension has been around
where the money for that 40%
pay rise could come from.
And to help explain why,
here's "Wsjs Autos" reporter Nora Eckert.
- Okay, webcam, sorry George.
I might need to get warmed
up a little bit here.
This is coming at a time
where the automakers
are really focused on keeping
costs low where they can,
so that they can fund the
transition to producing EVs.
- [George] Part of that expense
is because the raw materials
needed to make Evs, can
cost up to 125% more
than those used in
internal combustion engine
or ICE vehicles.
- But the union has said
that the companies can
afford their demands
even as they're funneling
billions of dollars
into this EV transition.
- When the big three say
the future's uncertain
and that the EV transition's expensive,
remember that they've made
a quarter of a trillion
in North American profits
over the last decade.
- But when it comes to EV manufacturing,
the bigger concern for the
UAW is around job security.
See, the transition from making
gas cars to electric ones
is dramatically reshaping how
many auto workers are needed,
and what those roles are.
While tasks like installing
interior trim or fitting seats
are unlikely to change
much in the transition,
roles that center around
building the combustion engine
are at risk.
According to congressional research,
that could mean nearly
150,000 jobs are exposed.
And even Ford's own CEO, Jim
Farley once told a conference
the EVs would require 40%
less labor than ICE vehicles.
- But the automakers have assured workers
that as many of those jobs will
be transitioned as possible,
so they'll be moving folks over
from these ICE plants to EV plants.
- While jobs on combustion engine
and transmission production lines
are likely to be phased out,
new jobs in new battery
manufacturing facilities
will spring up.
But that could still present
a major issue for the UAW.
- The plan was to draw down
engine and transmission plants
and permanently replace them
with low wage battery jobs.
- See, most of the new battery factories
aren't 100% owned and
operated by automakers,
they're joint ventures.
GM has a factory with LG
and plans for two more.
Ford has plans for several with SK On,
and Stellantis has teamed up
with Samsung for its factories.
And the problem for the UAW
is that these factories aren't
automatically unionized.
- And the union is fighting
for the security of those future jobs,
which is really interesting.
- [George] But that
appears to be changing.
In December, 2022, the workers at LG
and GM's battery facility
voted to unionize,
and fast forward to the present day.
- GM has now agreed, in writing
to place their electric
battery manufacturing
under our National Master Agreement.
What this will mean for our membership
cannot be understated.
- The question now
is whether GM's agreement
will set the stage
for other automakers battery
facilities to follow suit.
If that happens,
it could drive costs up
for these automakers.
The average hourly labor
costs for a unionized OEM
is around $65 an hour,
according to industry data.
Whereas Tesla, which
currently isn't unionized,
has hourly labor costs
of around $45 an hour.
And so if these automakers
pay their workers union rates
at their battery facilities,
it could make them less cost competitive
compared to the likes of Tesla
or foreign manufacturers
like those in Asia.
- Throughout this whole
bargaining process,
the automakers have sort
of repeated this mantra of,
"We cannot be competitive companies
if our labor costs inflate
as much as the union's
demands would make them."
- But if automakers
don't come to an agreement with the UAW,
they may struggle to
make vehicles altogether.
- I've heard members who
wanna bring down the hammer,
strike all the truck plants,
hit the big three where it hurts.
And there is a time and place
for that, and believe me,
if the big three don't
continue to make progress,
that time's gonna be coming real soon.
- So even though the strikes
have gone on for weeks,
this could just be the very beginning
of a long road ahead for the UAW.
(dramatic music)